basic principles no woman wakes up
saying god I hope I don't get sucked off
my feet today now she might say
something like this is a bad time for me
right now or something like I just need
some space or my personal favorite I'm
really into my career right now you
believe that and neither does she you
know why cuz she's lying too that's why
you understand me lying it's not a bad
time for her she doesn't need any space
and she may be into her career but what
she's really trying to say is get away
from me now or possibly try harder
stupid but which one is it sixty percent
of all human communication is nonverbal
body language thirty percent is her tone
so that means ninety percent what you're
saying and coming out of your mouth of
course she's gonna lie to you she's a
nice person she doesn't want to hurt
your feelings what else is she gonna say
she doesn't even know you yet see
luckily the fact is that just like the
rest of us even a beautiful woman
doesn't know what she wants until she
sees it and that's where I come in my
job is to open her eyes basic principles
no matter when no matter what and no
matter who any man has a chance to sweep
any woman off her feet
he sings the right room